- Was ist?
- Meine Kollegin Manja ist krank.
Ich mache morgen Manjas Unterricht.
- Ist doch super.
- Ja und was mache ich mit Emma?
- Wann beginnt der Kurs?
- Um neun.
Das geht nicht.
- Wann arbeitest du morgen?
- Ich arbeite morgen von acht bis zwölf.
Und nach dem Mittagessen
hab ich Volleyballtraining
und das Training ist von zwei bis vier.
- Und du, Nawin?
Wann hast du morgen Uni?
- Ich bin von neun bis fünf in der Uni.
Also den ganzen Tag. Tut mir Leid.
- Was macht Nina morgen?
- Nina hat morgen um acht
einen Termin beim Arzt.
- Und danach ist sie von zehn
bis drei in der Schule.
- Hm …
- Es gibt keine Lösung. Ich rufe Manja an.
Wir sagen den Unterricht ab.
- Nico ist doch da.
- Wie bitte?
- Nico, passt du morgen auf Emma auf?
- Emma?
- Babysitting.
- Ja! Gerne!